Hello. This is
Six Minute English
from BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Switch on the TV
or read a newspaper and
it's full of bad news
about the environment.
But climate change is damaging more
than just the planet's health.
It's affecting human health, too.
A growing number of people around
the world are experiencing something
psychiatrists are calling eco-anxiety.
Eco-anxiety involves feeling grief,
guilt, fear or hopelessness
about the future of the planet
due to climate change.
Of course
direct victims of
climate change
suffer most. Flood survivors
experience depression and anxiety
and people breathing polluted air
are at a higher risk of dementia.
But according to the Institute
of Psychiatrists, just reading
about the state of the planet in
the news is causing stress and anxiety.
In this programme
on eco-anxiety
we'll be learning some useful vocabulary
related to this worrying topic
and hopefully be hearing some happier
environmental news as well.
I hope so, Neil.
With so much bad news
it's sometimes hard
to feel optimistic about the future.
Well, here's a question
about some good climate news
for a change. In Australia, an animal
thought to be extinct
has been spotted for the first
time in over 50 years,
but what is the
animal? Is it
A. a shark , B. a lizard
or C. a parrot?
Hmm. I'll guess
it's a shark.
OK, Beth.
I'll reveal the answer later.
Unsurprisingly,
many of those suffering
from eco-anxiety are
young people.
When BBC Radio 4
programme, Woman's Hour,
spoke with veteran
environmentalist Judy Ling Wong,
they asked her if she was worried
for young people today.
I have tremendous
compassion for them
because what a mess
we have left the world in, our
generation, and the generation before.
Of course, you know, the science is
so advanced now...very much
in the past, the science would say,
yes we think, perhaps...we perhaps have
this models...
now we have the exact science,
so it is an absolutely
different ball game...
we actually know what to do now.
It is about getting on with it,
and the young people
are the furthest
ahead in this.
They can see the future as theirs
and they're impassioned
to do something about it.
Judy feels compassion,
a strong feeling of sympathy for
young people and the wish
for them not to suffer.
She blames older generations
and uses the phrase
'what a mess' to emphasise
that the planet is in bad shape.
You can use the phrase
'what a something' to intensify
the thing you're talking about.
For example, if someone gives you
a birthday present,
you might say
'What a nice surprise!'
But Judy is optimistic.
The science on climate change is
much more accurate than it used to be.
For example, we know that moving away
from fossil fuels would be a big help.
Science has changed the ball game –
the set of circumstances
that controls how a situation occurs.
Knowing exactly how to stop climate
change has impassioned young people.
They feel strongly motivated
to take action.
And as it turns out, taking action may
be one of the most powerful antidotes
to eco-anxiety. Actually doing
something to combat climate change
reduces feelings of helplessness.
Here's Judy Ling Wong again,
speaking with BBC
Radio 4's
Woman's Hour.
When the Institute
of Psychiatry
published its special issue
on climate anxiety, one of the papers
pointed out is that if you
can do something about it,
if you feel part of the
movement to change things,
or to stabilise things,
then you feel much better.
And also, you know, at the moment,
the government is
trying to reach net zero
by 2050 and all that,
and they committed to creating
two million new green jobs.
Now, if young people
and activists think about this,
if you have a green job
you're actually dedicating
your entire working life
to building a green
sustainable future,
and that has a huge effect
on your psychology.
Judy urges young people
to join a movement –
a group of people who
share the same beliefs and ideas.
Being part of the solution,
not the problem, helps reduce anxiety
and with new green jobs,
young people can protect
the environment
their entire working life –
the period of life spent
in employment
between leaving school and retirement.
And Judy's hopefulness is shared.
Recent polls showed that the majority of
people are worried about climate change
and are prepared to make changes.
Finally, some good news,
and speaking of good news,
what was the answer
to your question, Neil?
I asked which extinct animal has
recently been spotted in Australia.
You guessed it was a shark,
which was...
the wrong answer.
Actually, it was a lizard –
the earless grassland dragon,
a native to east Australia
that was last seen
in the wild in 1969.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we have learned from
this programme on eco-anxiety,
starting with compassion –
a strong feeling of sympathy
and the wish for people
not to suffer.
The phrase 'What a...something'
is used to intensify the thing
you're talking about. For example.
'What a mess!' or
'What a nice surprise!'.
The ball game refers to the set
of circumstances that controls
how a situation happens.
If you're impassioned,
you're emotionally motivated
to do something.
A movement is a group of people
with the same beliefs, ideas and aims.
And finally, your working life is the
period of life spent in employment,
between leaving school
and retirement.
Once again,
our six minutes are up.
Join us again next time here
on Six Minute English.
Goodbye for now.
Bye!